Okay, let's look at these questions.
So, the new algorithm on average, check fewer assignments than the original?
This is actually true and to see this the area all you have to look at is
the original has to check every possible assignment.
If it doesn't, then it can't know that it's actually the lowest assignment
whereas the new algorithm, as soon as it finds a vertex cover that works,
since it starts from the bottom, it knows that that is the minimum vertex cover,
so it knows that it can be done, so on the average,
the new algorithm will actually check fewer assignments than the original.
Now does the original algorithm sometimes look through fewer assignments?
This is actually false and again, the same reasoning applies.
The original algorithm has to look through every possible assignment,
whereas the new algorithm sometimes doesn't.
Now is the worst-case behavior of the new algorithm, in O-notation better than the original?
This is actually false and to see this, you just have to realize that
sometimes the new algorithm is still going to have to check through every possible assignment.
Sometimes that's the best minimum vertex cover you can hope to find
and since that's the worst case and it's the same as new algorithm,
the worst case behavior in O-notation is also just as bad as the original.
However, the best case behavior is actually better than the original algorithm.
The new algorithm does better in the best case.
The best case is that there happens to be a minimum vertex cover
of only one vertex and it checks that first.
And if it does, well then it's done whereas the best case of the original algorithm is still exponential
because it has to check every possible assignment, so the best case behavior is far better.
Now what about the average-case, how can we expect the new algorithm to behave on average?
Well actually, the new algorithm isn't on average as synthetically better than the original algorithm.
Again because it may have to check through just as many assignments as the original algorithm.
Now, this last question is tricky. How about the average-case behavior in the algorithm?
Compared to the original, is it better as synthetically?
This is actually false and this might be a little hard to see
but a good way of looking at it is to realize that on average,
the new algorithm is still going to have to check through
at least half of the possible vertex cover of all the possible assignments.
And there are exponentially many different assignments to the graph.
Well, half of the exponential number of assignments is still exponential,
so on average, the behavior of the new algorithm is still exponential which is just as bad as the original.
So, if you got that, great. If you didn't, don't worry.
That's kind of a tricky question but hopefully I got you thinking.
So if you have trouble with any of these, don't worry about it.
Some of them were a little bit tricky but hopefully they got you thinking.
Okay, that's it for this problem set. Hope to see you in the next unit.